hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about flip aces and flop paces
so first take a look at this drawing
that i have here we're going to be
talking about some enzymes flip bases
and flop bases that catalyze transverse
movement or transverse transverse
diffusion across the plasma membrane
so transverse diffusion
what this means is moving phospholipids
from one side of the lipid bilayer to
another side so if you look here we've
got some some enzymes we're going to be
primarily talking about these two today
but these are embedded in the lipid
bilayer remember by layer means two
two layers or two leaflets or two faces
so we've got the face that's up here
and the face that's down here and so
these flip faces and flop bases they
catalyze the diffusion of phospholipids
from one side
of the membrane to another so that's the
transverse diffusion sometimes it's
called like flip-flop movement hence
their names flip bases and flop bases
why do they do this to maintain membrane
asymmetry
now i have another video that goes into
much much much more detail
on membranes and how they are asymmetric
how
the basically the side of the membrane
that faces the outside of the cell has
different groups different
concentrations or frequencies
of phospholipids than the cytoplasmic
phase the face that would be like facing
this the cytoplasm
so
that membrane asymmetry is important to
membrane function
and these are the types of enzymes that
help to build and maintain that
asymmetry so these enzymes flip faces
and flow faces and also scramble laces
which i'm going to have another video
separate on scramblaces
these are transmembrane lipid
transporter proteins you can see in the
name exactly what they are they are
trans membrane proteins they span a
membrane and what they do they transport
lipids they transport lipids from one
side to another side depending on what
type they are
now these may be highly specific
highly specific meaning that a given
flip base or flop base may only
um allow the transverse movement of like
one specific type of
phospholipid or
some flip faces and flop bases may
transport multiple phospholipid types so
it just depends on which kind you're
looking at
mutations in these kinds of
transmembrane lipid transporter proteins
are associated with various diseases
i've listed some here angelman syndrome
tangier disease stargardt diseases are
pretty pretty rare
um but pretty consequential if you
happen to have one and they cause
defects in the activity of these
transporter proteins
so with that said let's now turn our
focus to flip bases and flaw faces like
i said i'll have another video on scram
laces so don't forget to check that one
out
so let's talk first about flip faces
i've drawn flip ace in here over here in
red so i'm going to switch to that color
here
flip bases are p4 atpases so they're
part of this family
of proteins they are powered by atp
hydrolysis
and you can see that right here so atp
has to be used has to be hydrolyzed that
terminal
third phosphate group
gets pulled off a bond is broken that
releases energy and it's that energy
that the flip base uses to drive forward
its process
so that's the atp hydrolysis
uh basically the cell has to expend
energy to get this these slip bases to
work
now movement this is the the major kind
of distinction between flip faces and
flop bases is which direction they're
moving things
so
um
the flip bases are moving
phospholipids from the
exoplasmic that is the
outside
face of the membrane or leaflet of the
membrane to the cytoplasmic
face
or the inside
face
and so i'm going to draw that right here
flip faces they are going to move
a phospholipid
from the outside
to the inside so make sure you see the
direction that this arrow is going
basically moving something from this
side to this side
and so i have some examples here abc a4
moves phosphatidyl ethanolamine that's a
specific kind of phospholipid so it's
going to move just that one so that's an
example of one of these highly specific
ones
another example aplt mousse
phosphatidylserine
and phosphatidylenolamine if you're
confused by some of these abbreviations
i'll put in the video description what
they stand for that's
phosphatidylserine is the ps
phosphatidyl ethanolamine is the pe
so now let's switch over to talking
about flaw paces so flaw paces are in a
different protein family in the abc
transporter family rather than the p4
atpase family
uh i've got quite a lot of markers in my
hands right now hang on a sec let me put
one down
uh i'm gonna switch to talking about
flop faces using a green marker
flop paces are also powered by atp
hydrolysis
so you can see again atp
that
terminal phosphate is pulled off that
bond is broken energy is released and
you can understand why this would be
you're having maybe not you i should say
the flip faces and the flop bases are
having to move
these hydrophilic heads
through
the the very hydrophobic
tails those fatty acid tails to get them
to the other side of the membrane
so it makes sense that some atp would
need to be used now this movement for
flop bases is in the opposite direction
of the flip faces so where the flip
faces move from the outside to the
inside the flop bases do the opposite
they move phospholipids from the
cytoplasmic or like the inner leaflet
facing the cytoplasm inside the cell
to
the
exoplasmic
face so basically moving from the inside
leaflet
to the outside
leaflet
and so i will draw that over here we're
going in opposite direction now
going from the inside
to the outside so again the direction
that these phospholipids are moving is
opposite between flow faces
and flop bases
so i've got some examples here abc a1 is
a flop base that moves
phosphatidylserine phosphatidylcholine
single myelin and cholesterol so it's
acting on a bunch of different ones
moving them again from the inside to the
outside face
another one that i
think is really interesting is msba
it moves lipid a from the inside to the
outside
specifically
in e coli
and why do i think that this is
noteworthy i used the wrong color there
were stuck with the green
uh white i think says noteworthy lipid a
remember that is the hydrophobic anchor
for
l
p s or lipopolysaccharide
right i'll write that here
lipo
polysaccharide
remember that is a major defining
component of gram-negative cell walls if
you want to learn more about
gram-positive cell walls and
gram-negative cell walls i've got a
really great video on that that you
should check out
so now
let's turn our attention for a minute to
biogenic flip bases these are maybe a
little bit of a misnomer
because biogenic flip faces
are more like scram laces really than
other flip faces but because they're
called flip faces i'm going to talk
about them here now scrambled laces we
haven't talked too much about but squam
laces
they move things
in
both directions
so there's those arrows to show you
movement in both directions and they're
energy independent meaning that no atp
is required so biogenic flip bases are
similar again energy independent
so unlike regular flip bases
no atp hydrolysis is required
these biogenic flow bases are located in
biogenic membranes what does that mean
biogenic is referring to where
the membranes
are primarily
synthesized
and so in prokaryotes this is going to
be
in the plasma membrane but in eukaryotes
like humans for example and eukaryotes
these biogenic flow bases are going to
be located in the endoplasmic reticulum
membrane so i'm going to abbreviate that
er endoplasmic reticulum and in the
golgi apparatus membrane so i will
abbreviate that ga so the goldie
apparatus or multibody
the er
and then in prokaryotes in the plasma
membrane that's where the membranes are
being synthesized and that's where you
have biogenic flip faces working these
are bi-directional
just like the scram blazes they can go
in either direction
but
the kind of major movement and i think
why these are generally considered flip
faces is because in general
these uh lipids are being synthesized um
in eukaryotes in particular
in the er
lumen so that's like in the inside
compartment inside the endoplasmic
reticulum and so they're having they're
being made there and so the ones that
need to
stay there can stay there but the ones
that need to be moved into the cytosolic
side or the cytoplasmic side
um they have to be moved and it's the
biogenic flow bases that do that
movement remember that um other faces
we're going from the outside to the
cytoplasmic side
cytoplasmic and cytosolic are in
interchangeable terms here but biogenic
flip bases also move lipids primarily
from in this case it's actually inside
the er but to the cytosolic site so just
like this right here
with movement flip-face movement to the
cytoplasmic side
this right here is movement to the
cytoplasmic side remember cytosol is the
aqueous component of cytoplasm that's
why we can use them interchangeably here
and then we've got our major
example
of a flip of a biogenic flip face being
the er flip face remember er stands for
endoplasmic reticulum i want to mention
one other thing and that's that
occasionally
you will hear
flip bases and flop bases and biogenic
flip faces and sometimes even scram
laces
all referred to as just
flip bases this is really not the most
correct the most correct is to to
characterize them
based on their energy usage and the
direction of transport to distinguish
between flip faces between flaw faces
between scramblaces but sometimes you
will hear just flip faces kind of as a
more generic term
so
don't forget to check out my other
videos like the one on scramblaces and
the one on membrane asymmetry and the
one on gram positive versus
gram-negative cells
let me know what you think in the
comments below please subscribe don't
forget subscribe hit that bell to get
notifications for my other videos and
thank you so much for watching biology
professor good luck with your studying
and i will see you next time